así
excelente trabajo pero supongamos que el
director decide que necesitamos robots
que tengan un poco más de variedad y
ahora necesitamos tres tipos de partes
cabezas cuerpos y brazos
cuando estamos combinando tres partes la
tabla ya no nos sirve
necesitamos encontrar otra forma de
pensar en todas las formas en las que se
pueden combinar tres partes distintas y
sería incluso mejor si podemos pensar en
una forma que funcione para dos para
tres para cuatro o muchos más tipos de
partes cuando estoy empezando a tratar
de resolver un nuevo problema a mí me
gusta romperlo en pedazos más pequeños
que son más fáciles de resolver
en este caso podemos empezar por contar
el número de robots hechos con dos
cabezas y tres cuerpos podemos ilustrar
las dos formas de escoger una cabeza con
una imagen como ésta y también podemos
ilustrar las tres formas de seleccionar
un cuerpo usando una imagen como esta el
problema con este tipo de imágenes es
que pueden hacer que parezca que tenemos
únicamente cinco posibles combinaciones
ahora antes de pasar al próximo vídeo
intenta combinar estos dos diagramas
para mostrar que hay seis tipos
distintos de combinaciones de robots